In this section, we will review the Mesh to MetaHuman workflow using the Template Mesh option.
This workflow allows for a metahuman identity to be solved based on the geometry input,
which results in a more precise match and better joint positioning for LODs.
Let's take a look at the requirements and steps of this workflow.
The Mesh to MetaHuman workflow using the Template Mesh option,
which can also be referred to as the Conformed Mesh option,
allows users to conform a metahuman identity by directly assigning a specific template mesh.
This forces a precise fit of the metahuman topology.
In order for this to work, the main requirement is that the input mesh
must already be conformed to the topology of the metahuman template mesh.
In the previous sections, we went over different approaches for fitting metahuman topology to a scanner sculpt.
This workflow allows us to use the fitted metahuman head geometry asset as an input
and results in getting the geometry and joint positions closer to the target delta across all LODs.
Now let's move on to the next section where we will work through a hands-on exercise
to create a metahuman identity with the Mesh to MetaHuman workflow using the template mesh option.